so
yeah this should work okay great so
um next we have a jonas haffer camp from
itp berlin
and he'll tell us about linear growth of
quantum circuit complexity
thanks a lot also thank you for having
me for inviting me
um yeah as it was announced i'm going to
talk about
growth of complexity and random quantum
circuits and a result that we proved
recently
i was lucky enough uh to collaborate on
this project with philippe feist
naga kutta konda yens isa dently called
young
which is this beautiful group of people
and then
you can find the project under this
archive identifier but of course you can
also just google the title
so the key concept in this talk
as the title already suggests is going
to be quantum complexity and complexity
in general is an extremely well
established subject
subject and sort of a ubiquitous
quantity
and this is not very surprising because
in in
full generality obviously everyone who's
interested in any kind of operation
usually wants to know whether the
implementation of this operation is
going to be
easy or whether it's going to be hard
so it's not surprising that the
classical analog of the quantity
of one notion of the quantity that i'm
going to talk about
is sort of one of the most pervasive
objects in
classical computer science so here it is
related to things like
separation of complexity classes
communication complexity
or derandomization but in physics even
quantum complexity or the notion of
complexity that i'm going to talk about
makes sort of surprise
appearances like in the definition of
topological phases of matter
so for example in this very workshop
earlier this week
chin maniac gave the talk about
precisely this and about the relation
to quantum circuit complexity and
perhaps most important at least for the
motivation
for the results in this talk is an
application
in the ads cft correspondence where
circuit complexity is conjectured to
correspond to quantities
in black holes volumes of regions in
black holes
beyond the event horizon
so i said complexity a lot and maybe now
is a good
time to specify exactly what i mean by
circuit complexity
so every unitary i think this is sort of
a foreclosure result can be implemented
using
something like four to the n many two
local gates
and it can be exactly implemented like
this
and the circuit complexity is then
simply the minimal number of such gates
that you need to decompose a unitary
and there's two things that i would like
to point out early on which is
i'm going to talk about unitaries the
entire time but everything
in this talk can be defined and proven
also for states
so this is not restricted to unitaries i
think it's just easier to stick to one
of the results
and the other one is this picture here
it shows nearest neighbor gates but
in the circuit complexity i also allow
for
non-geometric uh decompositions like
the first gate acting on the first qubit
and the 17th cubit or something like
this
so this notion of complexity similar to
the classical notion of complexity
is notoriously hard to feel or estimate
or even to bound
the classical case here i already said
it's related to the separation of
complexity classes so it's not very
surprising that it's actually extremely
difficult to make progress for explicit
boolean functions
and something very similar can be
expected for specific states or
unitaries
but then if it's so super hard to to
feel or estimate this quantity then what
is this talk going to be about
and the answer is it's going to be about
generic properties of complexity
or generic behavior of complexity so the
question that i would like to ask is
is complexity for example something
extremely exotic
that we would only expect to see rarely
or if it's
on a fine-tuned system or is it
something that's extremely generic and
we should
should expect to see it all around us
all the time and then if you have an
interactive system a typical one not a
specific one
then what what's the sort of behavior
that we can expect from complexity for
most
most of these and luckily there's
already a conjecture in the literature
um and it's by brown and susken
adam brown and what they conjectured is
that in a typical
locally interacting system what you can
expect is the following
it the entanglement sorry sorry the
circuit complexity should grow
at a linear rate until it saturates
after an exponentially long time
and this is motivated by various things
but for one reason we know that this
definitely holds in this very early
regime
because of growth of entanglement and
circuit lower bounds that can be deduced
from this so
the emphasis here is on on the
exponential times
that this holds until exponential times
and then it saturates
so before i come to before i talk about
why i believe that this is true and why
people in general believe this is true
um let me specify what i mean by typical
local dynamics because there's various
things that can be met by this and here
we have a specific
model in mind and i would like to point
out earlier that for example
using suggesting that proving things for
this model
should be easier than in other cases was
for example pointed out in this
paper by brandau chemisani hunter
and i really like to point out this
paper because
it got me interested in the question at
least and it also proves some beautiful
complementary results but i'm coming to
that later
so here's the model that we have in mind
and that's called
random quantum circuits and here we
previously fix
some way of arranging the gates but
first it doesn't matter or any possible
fixed arrangement would be possible
and then each of the gates is drawn
uniformly from the unitary group or the
special unitary group
onto cubits and i say uniformly
and here in the slide i use a very fancy
word which is the har measure but
if you don't know what this means it is
really
the it is the generalization really of
drawing uniformly from an interval
so um there are some specific
architectures that we should have in
mind
so for example there's the so-called
brickwork architecture that's called
like this because it looks like
brickwork
and then we could also for example
define something that's called a
staircase
and there's something that i would like
to introduce
now because now it's as good a time as
any and it's these
these light cones that are drawn into
this diagram
so later on i'm going to need the notion
of a complete light cone and this just
means that we have some cubit it doesn't
matter which qubit
we just need the existence of a qubit
and then we want
paths that go sort of backwards in time
and visit every qubit
so this is what i mean when i say a
complete backwards light cone
so now that we know what kind of model
we are talking about which is by the way
it is a
time dependent model so we throw time
dependence out of the window and in
return we get a very nice model
where we can prove things so why do we
believe that this is true
here well the first reason is really the
unitary group is a vast
space at at least for the linear growth
part this is
uh the unitary group has fought to the n
many parameters
and we can expect that very few circuits
actually cancel each other out
very few arrangements of baits so the
set of unitaries that we can generate
using circuits or that
become longer and longer sort of become
becomes bigger and bigger and we
would expect that the complexity keeps
growing with this
also the maximal complexity there's a
natural
upper bound which is just the number of
gates in the circuit
and we simply expect that the rate of
growth is just the same as the maximum
maximal possible rate then something
that i already
mentioned is at very early times you've
been proved that
or you can show that that entanglement
grows linearly
and with entanglement you can you also
get lower bounds on the circuit
complexity
so the idea here would be that if you
think about it
entanglements is sort of a phenomenon
that measures how
far is your state from a product state
and
while notions of entropy apparently
saturate after a polynomially long time
complexity could keep growing and simply
measure how far away are these states
from the
um from the from a product state
because this is really what complexity
is right it measures the number of
of two local gates that you need to
apply to your state or
to your unitary to bring it into
something that's product-like
and then a point which is
really um at the core of the motivation
of brown and saskand which is the
swarmhole growth paradox that i
mentioned before in this
in this dictionary that is the ads cft
correspondence
you have on the one hand the volume of
wormholes and on the other hand you have
something in a quantum theory
but the problem seems to be that the
volume of
black holes seems to grow at a steady
rate
for an exponentially long time but
observables local observables and
quantum theories tend to thermalize very
quickly
and the conjectures therefore that on
the quantum side we don't have local
observable but instead something that
depends globally on the state
and this is conjecture to be the
complexity
so this was the linear growth part but
the
and it's actually the more speculative
part because the other one is just the
saturation
and this is not very surprising in the
end
because we know i already said this that
every unitary
can be implemented using four to the and
many gates something that scales like
this
so we know that the circuit complexity
cannot keep growing after
after a time that scales like 4 to the n
and also we know that most unitaries are
in fact extremely complex
so once we've hit this threshold that we
can implement
basically every unitary the probability
of hitting
one of these very low complexity
unitaries becomes
extremely low and this is also something
that i would call a foreclosure result
and there are various proofs for various
different notions of complexity
but in our case there's a particularly
simple argument
and it really fits into this line well i
said it's a gigantic group it has four
to the n many parameters
but the number of parameters in a random
quantum circuit
or in any circuit with our gates is
upper bounded by the number of gates and
the dimension
of the unitary group one for cubits
which is 15
it is for the special unitary group so
we know that this should generate some
set of unitaries which
we believe to be lower dimensional
than the entire unitary group and
therefore it should be of measure zero
and the entire idea behind our project
is really actually
extremely simple it's just well can this
letter
argument be refined to also encompass
the situation where we not
compare all unitaries to the set of
unitaries generated by
some circuit with our gates but to
compare
two different circuits namely one with a
linear number of gates and one with
fewer gates
and so therefore also prove this linear
growth part
and this is what we get we actually can
do this and prove
the following theory so this is why i
said we need light cones because here
the lower bound depends linearly and the
number of disjoint backward light cones
that i can fit into my architecture
and i'm going to give you an example
soon of how this bond looks like in sort
of a
prototypical example so we have a random
quantum circuit and some architecture
and again
t is the number of backward light cones
that i can somehow fit into the circuit
then this immediately gives me a lower
bound on the
circuit complexity that scales like t
divided by nine minus n
over three and also i i want to say
earlier and you shouldn't worry about
this n over three it's just an
artifact of pushing the scaling down to
nine instead of 50.
it doesn't really matter especially in
the regions that we care about which is
exponentially large gate counts
and this bound it holds with probability
one and actually not just for
exponentially long time but in fact
until we've hit this dimension threshold
so i think the most interesting example
is probably just the brickwork circuits
and here it looks like this
we can fit a backwards light cone into
every n squared gates basically
so the number of gates divided by n
squared divided by nine
gives us the slower bound on the circuit
complexity in the brickwork architecture
so there's another thing that i find
quite remarkable which is
for that we can prove this for many
different architectures and in fact we
can show
in we do this in our paper we show that
this holds for most architectures so if
you
not only draw so sorry if you not only
pick a fixed architecture but you draw
the position of the gates at random as
well
then for most architectures you get a
linear lower bound with an inverse
polynomial scaling
right so for the rest of the talk i'm
trying to be ambitious and i would like
to give you a more or less complete
overview of how we proved this because
modulus some borrowing details it's
actually a very simple proof
and i said i want to i want to compare
dimensions of different sets of
unitaries generated
in different architectures and for this
i need to view
the set of unitaries as the image of the
smooth map
well the smooth map it takes as input a
set of gates this is an element of su4
to the r
and then it just contracts these gates
along these
along this previously fixed architecture
and this generates some set in the space
of all unitaries and you see
for example a visualization of this set
here and obviously we cannot really
visualize them because these are
extremely high dimensional sets
but you already see a property of the
sets in this image
that's going to be crucial for what we
want to prove
namely you see sort of a tube and you
see spheres which is just a collection
of many faults that are sort of stitched
together
and in fact i want to talk about
comparing dimensions
so i need to have a rigorous notion of
what a dimension actually is from one of
these sets of unitaries that are
generated by
quantum circuits and even architecture
and it turns out that there's an
extremely satisfying answer
at least for me unfortunately these are
not many faults
but they are the next best thing so
there's something that's called the task
is eidenberg principle
and it tells us that if we have a
polynomial map then the image is going
to be semi-algebraic
what the semi-algebraic means it's a
very complicated sounding term but in
fact it just means that you have the set
of solutions to some polynomial
equations and inequalities
and i want to give you like a very
simple example
something that is the set of solutions
to um
to a polynomial equation a prototypical
example of this would be sort of the
sphere
it's x squared plus y squared plus z
squared equals one
and then you can apply a map to this
that's
entries are polynomial in this space
and this the map that i want to think
about is of the projection into the xy
plane
and this gives us something that's not a
manifold anymore well in this example
it's a manifold with boundary but this
doesn't
this doesn't generalize but in fact it
can be decomposed into too many faults
namely is
a one-dimensional boundary and a
two-dimensional sphere
and this is one of the properties that
we want to use namely that this can
always be decomposed like this
and in fact we get a highest dimension
and then we can just say oh well this is
a good
definition for the dimension and also i
should say we didn't come up with this
definition that existed before obviously
so now we want to use this notion of
dimension to actually compare things and
the following lemma
really you would think that it's it's
not very surprising and in fact
we yeah we weren't surprised by this
because
you know if you have a c and a point and
the probability is zero but the problem
here is that we have
sort of an implicitly defined
probability measure on the set u of a
which is we actually draw the gates at
random uniformly and then we contract
so if you want to have the probability
of a set in this u of a
set then you have to take the pre-image
under this contraction map so it's not
immediately obvious that it works but it
does work
and we just have to figure out some
details to show
that everything works as we expect so
what do we prove we can show that
if you have an architecture a prime and
it generates a set u of a
which is a strictly lower dimension than
for a
and if we draw at random from the
architecture a a unitary
then the probability of hitting any
unitary that can be decomposed in the
architecture a prime
is of probability 0. so what does that
mean
that means first of all that every
unitary that has a given circuit
complexity
uh it falls into one of these
architectures
which with a low gate count and
for each of these architectures we
actually have a linearly upper bounded
number of dimensions
i said i mean this is basically the
argument that i gave before that if you
have any architecture then it can be
upper bound at the dimension
by the number of gates or something that
scales like the number of gates
so if we now want yeah quick question um
oh sorry i haven't said um so i i meant
uh wait i meant to define u of a
as the image of the smooth map for a
given architecture
so i was just too quick with the slides
um
so if you have a fixed architecture then
the set of all unitaries
that you can possibly get from
contracting
gates in this architecture is the set f
of a
does that clarify and what do you mean
by contraction do you mean just
simply applying the gates like taking
the tensor products right and then
multiplying the unitaries i see
it's really maybe um yeah so it's really
just a standard thing that you do in
quantum computing
and this is a power number this is a
polynomial map
because in each matrix taking the tensor
product with the identity is a
polynomial map matrix
sorry matrix multiplication is a
polynomial map and also something that i
haven't said before
the unitary group is an algebraic set
because it is just a set of matrices
that satisfies the equation
u times u dagger equals the identity and
if you want special
unitaries then you just need to have the
additional polynomial equation
determinant of u equals 1.
so this all actually works out
if this uh if this um clarifies the
question then what i wanted to point out
is that
um so so this is new to me so
so i should be thinking about the
variables as being the
coefficients of the individual uh
little unitaries is that right as i'm
trying to understand the underlying
uh dimension sorry not dimensions but
just variables in the space it's just
the entries of the unitaries
of the is that right yeah exactly yeah
we think about it as we sort of embed
matrices
in r to the n times n and then
also we don't take the complex numbers
but actually the real numbers in the
complex numbers
so it's two times n times n
okay and so this is some complicated
manifold and
yeah the point is it's unfortunately not
a manifold but it
yeah but it is some complicated object
that we really don't understand and
the lucky thing is for this restricted
notion of complexity this exact
implementation complexity it turns out
that we don't need to understand much
about the set except its dimension
and this is basically the entire point
sorry and then just remind me the
dimension of this how do i
if i just had us had a structure or
the dimension is right the point is that
we can show
you like invoking this this old result
we can invoke we can show that it
actually decomposes into many forms
so it is not a manifold but it's next
like for all practical purposes it is
manifold right you can see it as sort of
a
collection a weird collection or
manifold with corners
and like intersected by strings
or whatever so actually if i was
crawling around in the space i just want
to find this place where i have most
movement and that's my dimensions that's
the point exactly let's just take the
biggest
in terms of dimension you just take the
biggest space
so what i try to point out is that well
we have a linear upper bound
on the set of gates with a given circuit
complexity
and now it just we this lemma tells us
that now we just need to find a lower
bound on the set on the dimension u of a
um for a circuit
architecture for which we want to prove
linear growth like the brickwork
architecture so think of the brickwork
architecture for a and for the brickwork
architecture we want to prove lower
bounds
and now we need to find the lower bound
on the dimension of the set of unitaries
generated in the brickwork architecture
for example so it all sounds very
complicated
this u of a and these these complicated
sets but i promise you that we have
gained something
we have taken this mythological creature
that is the circuit complexity
and that definitely requires vacuoline
strength to struggle with
and we replaced it by something that's
extremely
well behaved and we did this by not
considering particular unitaries but
instead finding sort of a proxy quantity
that can only be assigned to the set of
all unitaries
that are contracted in a given
architecture
and i would like to argue why i believe
that this can be represented by a kitten
and it's basically this point the
dimension of u of a
is just the maximal rank of f of a
i'm going to explain soon what i mean by
rank but maybe some of you already
know this notion for example from like
analysis classes
for higher dimensional analysis classes
so
the dimension is the maximal rank and
the rank is defined for each point and
this means that
we can find a lower bound by finding a
single point that has a high rank
because by definition of maximum rank it
really lower bounds the maximum rank
and therefore it lower bounds dimension
and so the thing that we need to do
in the rest of the talk is really just
find a single point
that generates a lot of number of
parameters right
that we're taking the contraction and
small perturbations you get a lot of
unitaries from these perturbations
and more formally this is from this is
just the
rank of the so-called jacobian and the
jacobian is just this matrix
in some parameterization of f of a f a
meaning the contraction map where the
columns are just the partial derivatives
this map so how does this look like
in our case in our case it has a very
pretty picture i think these partial
derivatives
and partial derivatives you get from
taking the derivative
of some parameterization and in
particular you could also view them as
the first
term in the taylor expansion if you have
like an infinitesimal perturbation
or some infinitesimal rotation in our
case
and for some infinitesimally small
unitary i should say
something that's infinitesimally close
to the identity these can be uniquely
parameterized or written as the
exponential
of pauli matrices poly matrices being
tensor products of x
y z and the identity
so these are the parameters locally that
we want to take the partial derivatives
of and we want eventually
to see eventually we want to see that
these span
a high dimensional space because then we
have in a fixed point
a high rank or a linearly lower bounded
rank
and because this lower bounds the
maximal rank it lower bounds the
dimension
and we are all happy and have a linear
lower bound
and these partial derivatives in this
case they really look like
simply inserting a poly matrix or two
letter paulie word after gates
so the rest of the talk is just a very
simple combinatorial problem
where you just have to find a lower
bound
on the number of different pauli
operators that you can generate by
inserting poly operators into a circuit
and i should say usually if you've
insert poly operators into a circuit the
outcome if you for example
commute these through the circuit you
get something that's hermitian
but you don't get a paulie operator and
since we only need some specific example
it's easiest if we pick something that
we can easily work with because
comparing poly operators is easy they
are an
orthonormal basis of the hermitian
matrices and if you have n different
poly operators
then you have an n dimensional space
so here we pick just the unitaries such
that
conjugating poly operators by these
unitaries
they give us poly operators again
and that there's a group that's defined
by this
and it's simply the the clifford group
so that's basically the definition of
the clifford group conjugating how these
by them
gives you paulies and in this case for
example to commute this to the right you
would have to conjugate this poly
operator
by these two gates here and this would
give us
a four letter pauli operator
and so for the rest of the talk which is
just basically this
slide essentially
[Music]
we want to actually construct a given
set of
for for a given architecture that has
enough backward light cones
i want to construct a specific point
namely a specific
configuration of gates such that by
inserting poly operators after the gates
we can generate a lot of different
independent poly operators
and for this you have to believe me
something technical first which is
if i give you an arbitrary poly string
and
any backwards light cone complete
backwards light cone
then i can always pick these gates as
clifford gates
such that commuting this entire poly
operator through the circuit
gives me a single qubit that operator
and because we wanted to do this in full
generality if you look it up in our
paper it looks very complicated but
hopefully this picture already convinces
you
that we can always do this because the
point is that
the clifford group actually maps all
non-trivial pauli operators meaning
non-identity poly operators to all
non-trivial power operators so for each
pair of poly operators
i can find a clifford unitary that by
commuting one of them i get the other
paulie operator
and we can do this on on two paulie
operators whenever we have a gate in
front of them
so we could for example pick this gate
such that conjugating these two
gives us the identity that if these
two are non-trivial or if one of these
is non-trivial
and if not then we simply pick the
identity gate and we can keep doing this
until we hit the
the pauli z operator and because we only
leave identity operators behind we know
that's a single qubit set operator
but this single qubit operator it was
inserted into the circuit after a gate
right
and so it's one of these partial
derivatives that i talked about before
so basically what we have just shown is
i can take for any poly operator
a backwards light cone or a circuit that
has a complete backwards light cone
and choose the gates such that now
this entire poly operator times the
circuit is one of these partial
derivatives
well and we can simply use this to now
inductively construct the circuit
assume we already have oh sorry i used
the word here that i didn't want to use
um assume we already had like t
prime many backward light cones and
like this we already constructed a lot
of
paulie operators by commuting them
through the circuit
such that these are all independent so
these are all different poly operators
and i have t
prime of them many of them so what i can
do next is i simply pick
any poly operator that's not in this set
and i can always do this
unless we've hit this 4 to the n minus 1
threshold because
that's the number of non-trivial poly
operators
and then i can choose the next backwards
light cone
such that now this new pauli operator is
in the set
of of derivatives
and it means by appending this
this backwards light cone to the
previous circuit i have increased the
rank
of this point by one and therefore we
have a linear lower bound in terms of
the number of backward light counts
and this is already the entire proof
basically
this is already how we prove it modulo
some of these
differential topology details to make it
completely rigorous
so what have we achieved i think we have
achieved something that's like a minimal
version
and within with a capital m i should say
a minimal version of what was
conjectured by brown and soskin
and there's a lot of room for
improvement the first
part that i would like to improve is the
notion of complexity that we use in
particular we used a
complete completely
exact notion of circuit complexity and i
think in any real world scenario
you would allow for a small
implementation error
so i actually would like to show
something that
the circuit complexity of approximating
a unitary up to some reasonable error
grows linearly with time until it
saturates after an exponentially long
time
and we have a partial result but i warn
you it's really underwhelming
so we can't show exactly this with a
probability arbitrarily close to one
but the error is uncontrollably small
right now i don't know how this error
scales with the system size and we
definitely believe it to behave
but as far as we know it could scale
like inverse triple exponential
or something like this fortunately for
us
we kind of know what we might have to
understand
even though it will be very difficult
certainly and it
is related to the question of how curved
these spaces are
because making this robust corresponds
to sort of taking a thickened version of
these sets
and see how the volume behaves and
seeing how this scales with the system
size
depends on depends on the curvature of
these spaces
then another approach which is
completely orthogonal i think
is to use t designs unitary t designs
meaning probability distributions on the
unitary group that mimic
the har measure up to teeth moments if
you could show
that random quantum circuits generate
t designs unitary t designs and a depth
that's linear in n
and t and you could show something even
stronger namely that you cannot even
distinguish
these circuits using measurements with a
low complexity
from the most useless quantum channel
namely the quantum channel that sends
every every state to the maximally mixed
state
this was established this this
connection was established here in this
paper by brandow chemistry hunter jones
king and preschool
and they also use it or use previous
results on unitary designs to actually
show that
this notion of complexity also grows
even though it's a sublinear group
also i should say it is linear in the
limit of large local dimensions
so this was the first part this was the
error tolerance then something else that
comes to mind is obviously that we've
chosen a very particular
simple model of local
unitary dynamics and of course we could
also think about for example
ensembles of time-independent
hamiltonians or even something that's
called the thumb of your double state
which plays big role in the swarm or
growth paradox
and here there's a lot of evidence most
of which based on computational
complexity assumptions
so there's a lot of really cool work
that was done here
but proving this unconditionally i i at
least i have no angle of attack even for
ensembles of
hamiltonians because we make crucial use
at least our approach doesn't work
because we make crucial use of the fact
that
we keep adding new degrees of freedom as
we add gates
so i think i'll stop here and we still
have
lots of time for questions if there is
any
question
i i have one question so from the
beginning you're looking at this in
terms of uh
two cubic gates would it also make sense
to look at this in terms of ta
complexity
um you mean t local or something like
this
in the sense of like if you're doing a
fault dollar simulation
aren't what's characterizing the
complexity but rather the number of
knots that you're getting
i'm sorry i'm not sure i i caught this
so
i understood like taking for example
three local gates or something like this
like if we yeah clifford clifford
um so we have clipper gates and then we
consider the non-clipper gates just the
t-gates
these are so uh tj's
yeah i i i got it now and the idea
it doesn't work here because this is a
discrete gate set
so the problem is that we keep comparing
dimensions and if we for example define
circuit complexity in terms of any gate
set that is discrete
then it has probability zero always so
it gives you a statement but it gives
you sort of a nonsensical statement
so we have to make crucial use of the
fact that we actually keep
that we generate higher dimensional
unitaries
so unfortunately in this case the
approach doesn't work
it seems like your argument will be
relied on clifford gates
if i understood that correctly yes
i mean does your lower bound
when restricted to clifford circuits
also your lower bound still holds right
or does it really rely on the far end it
really does rely on her randomness so
this is really
this this entire approach is based on
using continuous gates
or continuous spaces of gates once we
hit something that's discrete
the entire approach doesn't work anymore
and this is also why it doesn't work for
example
for something classical
because there you always have some
discrete sets of gates
but you're right the technique depends
on clifford circuits but we basically
chose clifford circuits for convenience
because we only wanted to have some
point that generates a high rank and it
turned out to be very easy to work with
clifford unitaries
but actually there's no reason to
believe that it's maximized in clifford
circles the dimension
so actually feel welcome to try to find
other points because once you find a
single point
that has a better lower bound on the
dimension you immediately
improve our results so for example it
might be possible to even get rid of
this inverse linear
or inverse polynomial scaling
it's just that you need to find better
better examples i have some ideas for
candidates
if anyone's interested drop me a message
but
so far i yeah i can't get better
advanced
sorry to follow up on that
so if i'm thinking of this thing as a
union of manifolds
what that proof said was somehow if you
take a point that actually
is a even is it a pally or a clifford or
something
from that point there are points that
have are mac or maximal in the dimension
right that the center is that
a clipper circuit is that right
yeah so basically yeah i take a
cliffhand circuit and then basically the
idea is
well if i if i perturb this clifford
circuit between sort of global clifford
unitaries
then does that generate many different
directions in the unitary group
and the idea is yes and probably i mean
it's very much related to the fact that
clifford's plus anything else is
universal
and in fact it was um the idea comes
sort of from something earlier where
we've showed
where we showed that if you have random
clifford unitaries
and then something else then you also
get t designs at least for low values of
t
so yeah we just constructed some example
we found this construction and it works
but
yeah please find a better example
and sorry just a very vague question
which was sort of the whole
setup was motivated by
i guess in my mind it sort of was
something about that this is very
natural to think of
our measure generated locally generated
circuits as sort of like the whole
framework for things yeah can you say
why is there anything you could say
about why
that that seems like the right
uh like that's what we care about
somehow
well okay i mean um to some degree
it is definitely motivated by the fact
that every local dynamics can be by
characterization sort of
made into this form on the other hand
um it's sort of a minimal
example at least there's also something
i tried to convey
that which sort of tried to prove a
minimal version and it's definitely to
some degree a toy model
because if you for example take a time
independent hamiltonian then you don't
get
new randomness every time you apply a
gate so it's sort of the simplest
example that i can think of at least
that has some locality to it
i mean the only answer is really it's
nick called it a tactical retreat
it's the simplest model that i can think
of that captures locality
great thank you could you say a bit more
quantitatively about what approximate
version of this you think
is uh expected like what's the notion of
approximation and what's the regime of
error
in that notion that's a very good
question i mean
the answer is probably that i simply
don't know um
i think approximation
up to some relative error where the
error is
fixed should also grow like say
one it's like everything up to something
like one plus epsilon
as a relative error i would still expect
everything to grow
linearly but the question is does it
grow
until you hit 4 to the n minus 1 because
this 4 to the n
is definitely maximal but it comes from
this dimension
approach right and so it might be that
they keep growing
linearly or almost linearly but not
until four to the end but they sort of
saturate earlier it's something i could
imagine and i could imagine that this
this region when it saturates earlier
that this definitely depends on the
error
and on the um on the notion of error
that you choose
but i would expect it to grow for a long
time
probably linearly simply because i
believe that this can be proven
i can't prove it i thought about it for
a long time and this would certainly be
the strongest notion of approximation
that i can think of
so not proving that it is actually um
some some implementation circuit
complexity but upper bounding the number
of gates that you need for a measurement
that distinguishes
distinguishes your unitary from the
completely depolarizing channel
so what part of this current proof is uh
sensitive to error
i guess your result holds with probably
one so
yeah so the problem is if you allow for
any any implementation error essentially
the sets of unitaries generated or the
set of unitaries that are close
to this are immediately of full
dimension
i immediately fought to the
n-dimensional sets
so any comparison of dimension
immediately fails so it's
the very notion of comparing dimensions
that doesn't work anymore
does that make sense right because i if
i want to allow for some robustness
i don't care anymore whether you hit
these unitaries exactly
but you have to allow for sort of a
thickened region every
point that's close and if you allow this
tubular region around your
set then you get something that's not
lower dimensional anymore so i can't
compare dimensions at all
basically i don't get an upper bound on
the dimension anymore
that fails all right
well um i think it's time to move on to
the next talk so thank you very much
jonas
so next up i think we should have david
costas